very good so I'm going to talk about the
joint work with Amit Danieli
who is it Hebrew University and Google
so this is talk about the power of non
interactive protocols in the local model
of differential privacy and we'll
explore that power in the context of
learning algorithms investor of a
classical act learning framework we also
think about this work as a work as work
about adaptive data analysis will be
understanding the power of that activity
in instead of solving learning problems
so let's start with a brief reminder
what a local model of differential
public see is I imagine most of the
people at this workshop don't need this
reminder but just in case you found this
video on YouTube and you haven't thought
I would give a reminder so in this model
we have say end users each holding their
own data and this user is interact with
a server that wants to compute some
function on that data and a protocol in
this and in this general setting the
order of interaction between the server
and the users is completely arbitrary
and restricted and the queries of a
server might depend on all the sort of
values that the server has observed so
far and at a protocol in the setting is
set to satisfy epsilon local
differential privacy if each of the
messages sent by each of the users is
sent using the local randomizers that
has this epsilon differential privacy of
property and for every users this is
very very user the sum of the Epsilon's
are used on its messages is upper
bounded by this F total epsilon budget
and this model is from the paper by kasi
Viswanathan Lee nice Emrys holding Kevin
Smith will be invoking this work quite a
few times in this
in this paper so I'll refer to it as
cleaners nickname so this is a very
powerful model we know how to solve
relatively sophisticated problems so
hard problems in this model but it is
also has been observed by many people
that in practice protocols that have
many rounds of interactions are
inefficient and and many cases are
basically impractical and this is due to
various kind of network latencies having
to synchronize between the users and
also general complexity of such a
protocols and as a result sort of the
particles that have been actually
deployed deployed in practice are
basically non interactive and what that
means that the server gets to pick some
set of queries since those queries
essentially imperil to all the users
obtains the responses then computes
whatever it needs to compute on those
responses after observing these queries
so and it's natural to ask what kind of
functions can be computed if you
restrict the protocols to be a non
interactive which is exactly the
question about what is the power what
what sort of what are the problems that
can be solved we want to find problems
that can be solved interactively but
cannot be solved if the protocol is
restricted to be non interactive so you
can of course explore this question in
the context of many different learning
problems the ones we'll be looking at
are so called the PAC learning framework
the classical framework of Valiant and a
problem in this framework is defined by
a class of functions that we want to
learn which will be denote by C and and
these are the functions are just binary
boolean of functions over some domain X
and an algorithm is said to be a PAC
learning algorithm if for every function
in that class
and for every distribution over this
domain X the algorithm is given iid
examples where an example is a point
drawn from this unknown distribution and
the value of the unknown function f on
that on that point given such examples
the algorithm outputs a hypothesis age
subject with high probability this
hypothesis disagrees with the unknown
function with probability at most alpha
where the probability is again taken
over this unknown distribution D so in
this basic framework it's assumed the
Albert needs to work for every function
and every distribution but we'll also
look at the version of this model in
which the distribution is effectively
fixed and known to the algorithm it's
often referred as distribution specific
learning and this version is referred to
as distribution independent a learning
so in our setting the examples are not
given directly to the algorithm are
actually these are they the examples are
held by each of the users in the local
protocol so in order to kind of argue on
understand what's known about learning
in with local differential privacy and
the smaller the sort of the main tool
that has been used there is another
model a restricted model of learning
which is referred to a statistical query
model defined by turns in 93 and in this
model we have an algorithm which instead
of having access to example themselves
has access to so called statistical
query Oracle for the data distribution
which will denote by P and I take the
distribution in our case for learning
problems will be the edges to the
distribution over the labeled examples
that we observe which is just the point
and its value where the point is drawn
from distribution D over the domain so
in this model a Cisco query algorithm
can ask we through this Oracle and each
query is defined by sort of us as we
usually define statistical query is a
function which maps a point in the
domain basically so a data point which
is an example to some to some range 0 1
and to this query an Oracle a response
the arbitrary value V which is close to
the expectation of this function on on
an element drawn randomly from this
unknown data distribution and the
closeness is measured using this
parameter tau the destructor is the
tolerance of the query and roughly
corresponds to the number of thumb
examples that the algorithm would have
in their in the standard model where the
correspondence is roughly you should
think of tau as being roughly 1 over
square root of n so it's roughly cause
most of the sample context so the
algorithm can ask additional queries
after observing the results and so on
and so forth and the reason why this
model is important is that is is the
fact that the also shown in my cleaners
that this that basically this model is
essentially equivalent to a local model
of differential privacy specifically
they show two simulation results both of
which kind of succeed with some
probability 1 over beta and will
restrict here and everywhere else
epsilon to be at most 1 so they show the
first simulation result they show that
any epsilon locally differentially
private protocol with and messages can
be simulated using all FEM statistical
queries with tolerance of being roughly
this beta a failure probability over m
and in the other direction they show
that any statistical query algorithm
with tolerance tau can be simulated by a
protocol one can simulate this Oracle
using a locally differentially private
protocol which has M examples where n is
roughly the number of queries divided by
the tolerance and epsilon squared and in
this case for the in the simulation one
obtains the protocol which only uses
each of the samples once so the number
of samples the same as the number of
messages
does it make sense so far so now
directly from these two simulations
okay so octave once I should have
mentioned that an important property of
this simulation results is is that the
local the protocol that one obtains is
non interactive if and only if the
statistical query out crisp onyx is a
query algorithm is non adaptive which
basically means kind of the same thing
in this context a statistical algorithm
means non-adaptive if all of its queries
are kind of non of this query depend on
the previous answer so that all the
queries are determined before observing
any of the answers from the oracle so
from this result one kind of directly
obtains the following equivalence class
of concepts see is learn about
efficiently in this model statistically
a statistical query of statistical
queries if and only if it is learn about
ficient li in local model of
differential privacy whereby efficiently
I mean that it's polynomial in the size
of the input and relevant learning
parameters and this equivalent also
preserves this adaptivity or
interactivity which in this context that
refer to the same thing so from this
result one can obtain immediately obtain
a bunch of nice corollaries for local
differential privacy from statistical
query algorithms for example one can
obtain that the class of linear
classifiers are also furthest
half-spaces
is allowable efficiently this is the
result of the Nagala but also obtains
that the class of parity functions it
doesn't matter if you don't know what
they are will not be learn about by
local locally differentially private
algorithms and though it's not to be a
learnable by central differentially
private algum also result from cleaners
and we also know that there are actually
very few learning Galvis which are
completely not non interactive but one
for one example of non interactive
algorithm is the learning of boolean
junctions which are simple very simple
functions so now using this tool makes
it much easier to separate the models of
interactive and non attractive that's
exactly what has been done by a cleaners
they show that there exists a class of
function that is learnable in this
statistic video or local differential
privacy efficiently or when one
restricts the the distribution to be
uniform over the this boolean hypercube
of dimension D but if you were to try to
learn this class known interactively you
would require an exponential number of
sample by LDP algorithm so it's a very
strong separation it's and as far as I
know it's not known for any other this
kind of strong separations are not known
for any sort of other problem in any
kind of domain as far as I know but
maybe I'm maybe I'm just missing some
literature so the way they show it they
basically it's a relatively simple
construction they show that the closet
they pick is so-called mass parity which
basically requires you once you solve so
in which one part of the domain is mask
using a key that can be discovered by
solving a learning problem on the on the
other part of the domain and that sort
of forces the algorithm to be
interactive so if you can first find
this key you can also make any
meaningful queries about this learning
problem so again the suppression is very
strong but it is kind of unsatisfying in
two respects the first one is that the
sort of the classes can it has been
designed specifically for this problem
it's not a natural problem at all and
the other sort of the construction is
here Klee only works for distribution
specific learning one kind of if one if
the length of the algorithm if the
decision was not restricted the
distribution could be all concentrated
on this masked part of the domain and
which
make it impossible to learn even for the
interactive algorithm so it is natural
to ask in fact has been explicitly asked
by cleaners does this separation hold if
one were if one were to look at a
distribution independent learning and of
course it would be interesting even more
interesting to separate these things for
natural learning problems so and this is
exactly the problem that we are going to
answer in this work to present the
result I need one more concept let me
know if you have any questions there
will be quite a few maybe concepts that
new for some of you and that is the
context concept of margin complexity so
let me first briefly remind you what the
margin is so for two sets in sort of in
Euclidean space of points one of which
is labeled positively and one of which
is labeled negatively we say that they
are separable with margin gamma if there
exists a separating hyperplane which
separates them the positive are on one
side of the negative are on the other
side and the distance from every any
point to the separating hyperplane is at
least come this is a standard classical
notion in learning and using this notion
the margin complexity of a class of
function C which will denote by margin
complexity C is defined as the smallest
M cited they exist an embedding from
this domain of the of the class X to the
unit ball in d dimensions such that
under this embedding each function
becomes linearly separable with margin
gamma which is at least 1 over m and
here by function becoming linearly
separable separable is basically means
that the positive examples of functions
are mapped and the negative examples
these two sets of points after being
embedded into this space become linearly
separable with margin-top that make
sense so this defines the notion of
complexity for class of functions that
and it's important both in learning in
fact has been also studied in
communication complexity so with this
notion we can give our sort of main
lower bound which stays the following
let C be any class of of boolean
classifiers that is negation close
meaning that if a function is in the
class then it's negation is also in the
class then any non interactive locally
differentially private algorithm would
say epsilon one that learns this class
in the PAC model distribution
independently with arbitrary error that
is less than half and non-trivial
success probability will need the number
of examples and messages which is at
least margin complexity of C to the
power two-thirds that's the main lower
bound let me spell out some of the
corollary x' that makes sense let me
spell out some of the corollary zuv this
result the first one for the class of
decision lists you might for those you
haven't seen this class each function
each decision list is defined by a
sequence of decisions and here the input
vector is is a d-dimensional boolean
vector and each decision checks can
check the value of one of the attributes
for example whether so the third
attribute is equal to one if the
condition holds it will output the value
of the function will be fixed to some
arbitrary plus or minus one if the
condition doesn't hold it goes to the
next decision and can do it for an under
arbitrary number of decision at the end
everything has to be determined so for
this class of functions we show a
corollary of our lower bound is that the
number of samples want me to learn it on
adaptively is two to the Omega basically
two to the D to the cube root of D which
is basically exponential in the
dimension D and this follows from a
lower bound on the margin complexity of
this class do two Oberman
they're shagging and evolved another
corollary so and the reason why it's
kind of separates these classes is that
as shown already by currents in 93 if
you allow interaction this class is easy
to learn with a number of samples which
is pulling on you in deal and I'll find
epsilon and the other is very simple
just peels off these kind of decisions
one by one until it learn it's kind of
inherently interactive algorithm and
another corollary one gets up from this
lower bound oh yes for somewhat more
general class of linear classifiers and
we'll again look at those over the
boolean hypercube for this class our
lower bound is that the number of
samples you need is actually exponential
in and as I have mentioned this class so
it falls from a lower bound on margin
complexity of of these linear
classifiers due to Goldman Hofstede
Andrus Borov and first office is the one
kind of notice that their result implies
lower bound on margin complexity and
here the the result that I have
mentioned this class is learn about
interactively with the number sample
which is polynomial in D over up so
Alpha Epsilon and this is a result due
to Dunnigan an event power
so that's the result let me and now ok
natural question is is this is there a
matching upper bound and we haven't sold
this question but we made some progress
which show also some upper bounds which
are in terms of margin complexity
pacifically we show that if you fix the
distribution D then and make it known to
the algorithm then for for any Class C
there exists an algorithm that will
learn this class C over this fixed
distribution D using a number of samples
which is polynomial in the margin
complexity of this class times whatever
the standard learning parameters and
while sort of knowing the D D might be
kind of a very strong and restrictive
condition we can relax it in two ways
there are one option is that if one has
access to public and labeled samples
from D though the the corollary will
still hold in fact we can also use a
kind of this hybrid model in which we
have non interactive access to label
examples but interactive LVP access to
only unlabeled samples from D one nice
thing
think about this in hybrid models it
actually our lower bound also holds
against this hybrid model and non
interactive access to two labeled
examples and interactive access to
unlabeled one so in that sense this
hybrid model is basically correct the
learner ability in this model is
characterized by the margin complexity
so now okay
that's basically the result no have any
questions so far
so this this learner nose deep or
alternatively alternatively it has
access to public unlabeled samples from
thee or alternatively instead of knowing
D it can have interactive access to some
users which who only hold the unlabeled
samples from the distribution there are
no they don't know anything about the
label but you're not sure if obviously
this upper bound holds ending like for
the distribution independent yeah yeah
so it's a fully distribution independent
but there is some kind of special access
to the distribution do you need to know
something about it instead of knowing it
you can replace it with some access to
samples but you're not sure if this is
necessary I don't know if that's
necessary
I suspect that it is anyway let me now
briefly you yeah you yes you know the
only thing you need is is to some to be
able to sample and even less than just
sample you'll see actually we might have
time to see the upper bound okay so let
me briefly describe you actually how
would we prove both of the results so
first of all the lower bound and just to
remind you basically using the
characterization by statistical queries
and kind of the contrapositive of them
of the main lower bound lower bound this
is can be stated as follows if c is a
negation close set of classifiers then
if exists and no a non adaptive Eskew
algorithm that uses two queries of top
each of tolerance 1 over Q then and SEC
and learn the class with some
non-trivial error then the margin
complexity of the closet has been
learned is it most of Q to the three
seconds is just it again the
contrapositive of the result AB lower
bound stated in the statistical query
framework to prove this result sort of
the main tool is is this kind of
correlation than the notion of
correlation dimension of a class of
function c from an earlier work by
myself and a correlation dimension of a
class c yeah is defined as the smallest
number T for which there exists T
functions which each of which is met
mapping the domain elements to this
minus one one size it for every single
function in the class C and every
distribution D there exists one of those
function that is has non-trivial
correlation with the unknown function so
we want to kind of cover the set of all
functions and all distributions with
some set of functions that are
correlated some small set of function
which correlated with each of those and
the reason why we need this dimension is
that has a simple relationship to that
to the margin complexity has been shown
by myself and then
Hartmann by Calvin and Simon that the
margin complexity of a Class C is upper
bounded by correlations disco Queenie
dimension to the power of three halves
and a two so now with this notion in
order to prove our lower bound all we
need to show that if there exists a non
adaptive statistical query that uses Q
queries of tolerance 1 over Q then this
collection of statistical period
dimension is at most Q and the proof is
pretty simple again we'll do it for
deterministic algorithm which makes it
even simpler in general somewhat differ
the fad for randomized algorithm or
complicated but not conceptually so so
let's assume that we have a non adaptive
statistical pretty algorithm which uses
Q queries and because these like non
adaptive we can assume that they're just
fixed in advance it's a fixed set of
ways now given this queries we can
decompose each created into two parts
one is which is this is kind of a simple
identity that one can check by just
plugging two values of the label Y so
each query can be decomposed in these
two parts and will refer to the first
part as G it kind of does not depend on
the on the label and the second part
which is just a product of the label
with with this function so we'll get two
functions out of each query and this
decomposition will gives us implies that
the expectation of each query that that
the Oracle estimates is just the sample
of expectation of this part this
function which does not again depend on
the target function plus the correlation
of the second part with the target
function just to the query now if we
assume that that so so now that we claim
that this set of H is this part of the
function for each of the queries will be
the certificate for for this cover for
this correlation dimension and to prove
this we assume that if this doesn't hold
then we'll arrive at the contradiction
in the following way so if this
correlation is at most one over Q then
basically the the answer to the query
with function f yes will be the same
essentially the same as the answer to
the query for the negation of the same
function because again this correlation
part is close to zero and then we only
left with part which does not depend on
the label and now if this holds for all
the queries this basically means that
the queries cannot distinguish there
exists some function for which the
queries cannot distinguish in the
function and it's negation if you cannot
distinguish between the function it's
negation you cannot learn with any
non-trivial accuracy so that's the end
of the lower bound and since I don't
have much time let me go and say
something briefly about the upper bound
it makes some sense so the upper bound
is just to remind you we want to give an
algorithm which learns in time
polynomial in margin complexity so and
to remind you the margin complexity is
sort of the smallest m under which there
exists embedding in some G dimensional
space where the functions become
linearly separable
what sort of Unknowing issues that this
the notion of margin compacts to you
does not say anything about about what
this dimension is it but actually could
be exponentially small so it doesn't
immediately lead to the algorithm but
there is a sort of a standard fact about
margin capacities that you can always
reduce this dimension to be much smaller
specifically you can use a random
projection and then get an embedding
into a space of roughly whose dimension
is a roughly margin complexity squared
and you'll lose only a constant factor
of the margin so you can reduce the
dimension to be roughly polynomial in
margin complexity now having reduced the
dimension all we need this to be able to
learn large margin classifiers in
relatively small dimension and the way
to do it well this is one way in our
paper this I think you can do it even
simpler let me see if I can convince you
so we will look at the sort of the
standard perceptron algorithm I imagine
most of you some of you at least have
seen it and what this algorithm does is
start with sort of all zeros vector
and then takes any examples if the
example if the sort of it maintain some
weight factor which describes a linear
classifier if the current half-space
does not predict labeled correctly then
it updates the weight vector by adding
to it the sort of this point multiplied
by its label and then repeats this
process until convergence so in our
setting of course we don't have the
example themselves it has been observed
that you don't in this distributional
setting instead of using example
themselves you can use sort of expected
updates which is just the expectation of
this update vector Y times X conditioned
on this example being a counter example
so you need to compute this as a this
expectation here is a vector and to
compute and sort of you can see here
that if you were to try to compute the
sixth occasion kind of depends on the
current the condition depends on the
current value of the vector so it is
kind of an adaptive algorithm but if you
look a little more carefully this
conditional expectation is just by the
definition of conditional expectation is
just the expectation of the product of
this vector times the indicator of the
condition divided by the probability of
condition holding the this probability
of condition holding is just some scalar
and actually not too small and all the
updates will go through if you just
don't quite if there have some
additional factor so all we need to make
sure is that we can estimate this
expectation now this expectation again
if you look at it a little more careful
is just the expectation of x times the 1
minus the sign of the sort of the value
of the current - current classifier
which is just the composes into the
expectation of the product of this XY
plus X times the sign of this condition
and from here one can you see that this
part is non adaptive because it's just
basically this vector is just
factor of correlation of each of the
attributes with the label and this part
does not depend on the label at all it
is it's another expectation but it is
adaptive it depends on the current value
of the current hypothesis but does not
depend on the label so if you know the
distribution you will you can just
compute these expectations easily so the
only thing I didn't tell you is how do
we estimate these expectations of
vectors in the LDP model or statistical
query model but it's a problem that has
been solved you can do it naively or if
you want to do it a little more in a
more sophisticated way you can use the
algorithm
you know LDP you can use the algorithm
by Gucci and others and if you want to
do it with statistical queries you there
is a paper by myself Cristobal Guzman
and Santos wind power so that's all that
I wanted to say about the upper bound
let me go to conclusions so first of all
just a brief summary we showed a new
approach to lower bounds for non
interactive LDP protocols which reduces
so they're sort of approach uses them to
a margin complexity lower bound and to
be fair most of the heavy lifting is
done by this margin complex two lower
bounds none of the results we are
relying on are is simple there could be
sophisticated results but once you get
this but because these notion is kind of
a classical notion it has been studied
especially in communication complexity
we do get some lower bounds for
classical learning problems and another
nice property of doing this all these
results we are statistical query model
is that we get essentially the same
result for another well studied model
which is so-called communication
constraint protocols where again is a
distributed protocol but each each user
can send on a small number of bits in
each round of interaction about their
data point again this model is also
equivalent to statistical queries and
you get so you get the same set of
results for this model so another
implication is that one can say that
interaction is necessary for learning we
in the context of adaptive data analysis
with we consider all these protocols
that ask statistical queries adaptively
but we don't have much evidence so we
don't know why where this is actually
necessary so this is one way to see that
this interaction or other activity is
necessary for achieving some for
learning in particular and let me
mention a couple of open problems saying
basically this entire area is a big open
problem so it's kind of much easier to
state and pretty much at any question
huh no no matter how basic is probably
open let me mention just a couple of
those which are related to this work
first of all we don't get we would it
would be great to have a distribution
independent learning which is polynomial
in margin complexity or prove a lower
bound which is both probably more likely
the other thing which is kind of a
significant limitation of our lower
bounds is that they only hold against
completely non interactive or cortical
State I don't know whether they hold
even for protocols which use two rounds
of interaction and finally you sort of
okay these as I mentioned these
factoring problems are potentially not
the most interesting in the sort of for
modern practice of machine learning it
will be much more interesting to
understand what happens in stochastic
convex optimization and there we still
don't have any lower bounds for the LDP
but there is some progress that the
upper deep I think is going to talk
about later today that's it thank you
[Applause]
so so I mean lower bounce basically mean
that you cannot do that like at least if
you're trying to do known a track if you
want to implement a non-interactive
local protocol that's sort of the mean
to say the main result is there are
things that you cannot do so you may be
again unless you make some additional
assumptions and things like this we also
have an upper bound which is a learning
algorithm again depending on whether
there's something to fit fit your
problem I mean they're implementing it
it's kind of easy because it is a non
interrupted protocol the specific
algorithm there we give basically only
needs to compute the correlations
between the label and each of their
attributes something that we already
have existing protocols that do this in
practice so so basically that's pretty
easy to learn can be done
[Applause]
until 1:45